he is a eight-year quarterback in the
National Football League three-time Pro
Bowler who currently is atop the AFC
North right now at the three and one
Cincinnati Bengals fresh off the big win
in Atlanta he is Andy Dalton how are you
Andy do well are you um I'm better for
talking to you three and one in
Cincinnati at the quarter post point
with Joe Mixon out for two games if I
told you that prior to the season
starting what would you said yeah I be
very pleased with we're at you know I
think if you can break up the season and
the quarters the first quarter went well
three and one if we can you know keep
that pace we'll put ourselves in a good
position but good start to the year yeah
and so what does mix and bring to the
equation spend a couple weeks he's he's
been there and I'm assuming he's coming
back soon can you give me an update on
that and what he brings to the table for
you guys Andy yeah Joe so talented he
kind of can do it all a big back that
can run and catch the ball the backfield
he like I said he can do it all but he
brings a ton of energy I think that's
one thing that's contagious with him you
know it really rubs off on everybody I
mean you can even see last week he's not
playing
AJ catches a touchdown in the end zone
he I think he's the first one down there
to go celebrate with him running tackle
on him doing all that kind of stuff so
he's got a contagious energy about him
and it's really good for this office
yeah I'm gonna be honest with you I was
watching that all of us at the NFL
Network and I saw somebody in regular
civilian clothes run down that was Joe
Mixon that was him that was that was Joe
Mixon yes it was the first one and like
I say tackle they jainism okay and
that's why security wasn't called they
everybody knew that was Joe Mixon I just
couldn't see it was just a blur of a guy
in a regular shirt and I'm like who the
hell is that it was Joe Mixon it would
huh okay very good and do we are you
expecting him back this week do you
think he returns against the Dolphins
Andy yeah I mean I think you know that's
that's the path on so so we'll see how
it goes okay so now three and one I'd
love for you to take us inside the
locker room with Marvin Lewis if if you
can cuz so many fans see so many
franchises change coaches all the time
when
things aren't may be as successful as
hoped and yet he just keeps on keeping
on as the coach there how does the
relationship between this team and him
work to the point where you're three and
one I think for us we were we were very
happy to have Marvin back and I think it
it keeps the continuity of what we had
and I feel like there was changes that
were made you know other places that
kind of made the the feel around here
new we've got you know some new coaches
new players and so I think that that's
been a big part of you know the the good
the good thing that Marvin brings and so
for us we feel just really confident
with what we've done I think especially
offensively well bill laser has brought
sides and the way guys have responded to
this new offense that that we're doing
this year is has been great and so I
just got it like I say guy keep it
rolling well what makes that work your
offense
you guys look as good as any team in the
league right now you're putting up
points frequently it will
it seems Andy what what makes it work I
think guys are playing at a high level I
think guys were playing with a lot of
confidence and you know we just feel
like that we can't be stopped out there
and so I think if you have that mindset
and you know you mix that with with
talented players I think it can really
go a long way and so you know I think it
showed through the first four weeks and
you know I mean what a major win that
was for you guys on the road to come
back in that Stadium after Tyler Eifert
went down what was it like on your
sideline after a guy who you guys loved
so much and know how much hard work he
put into getting back from multiple back
problems to see that happen with his leg
yeah I mean it's you know it feels
terrible for him like you said he he put
in so much work to get back and we felt
like he was back to you know what he's
been and so you hate to see that for
for a guy that that has had to go
through so much like he has so you know
that was tough I think for us we we
realized on the field because we have to
put this behind us we can't we can't be
you know what the the negativity creep
into the rest of this game and so I mean
I think for us to be able to push past
that and to win the way we did was it
was huge but again we hated for Tyler
it's something you never want to see so
did Marvin pull you all together did
somebody say something you say something
before everybody got back out there yeah
you know at that point in the huddle
it's like you know obviously it it sucks
for him but we've got to keep going
you know the game still has to go on so
we've got to get our mind right and you
know it didn't happen right after it
happened we went three and out and then
they blocked the punt so it didn't it
didn't work out just in but you know we
kind of got it back at the end of the
game and and we were able to win it Andy
Dalton Bengals quarterback here on the
Rich Eisen show three and one getting
set to take on the three in one dolphins
let's talk about your your foundation
and your trip to Buffalo this preseason
and you getting a standing ovation from
the fans there that I'm sure part was
again still the fact that your touchdown
pass to Tyler Boyd eliminated the Ravens
and was the help that the Bills needed
to make the playoffs last year but it
seemed to me that it was it was of
standing ovation for you and you back at
them for the money that was raised just
that the outpouring of love you you you
received from Bills fans I'm wondering
where were where you stood on that
ovation there Andy yeah it's such a
crazy story the fact that you know we
through touch that threw a touchdown
pass that knocked off the Ravens that's
what we were thinking at that point okay
well now the Ravens aren't making we
weren't thinking anything about Buffalo
okay Buffalo's in then next thing you
know someone donates to my foundation
from Buffalo saying thank you and four
hundred and fifty thousand dollars later
over 15,000 donors I mean it's so crazy
so
for my wife and I we felt like you know
it's our duty to give back to Buffalo so
you know it was cool how it all line you
know God kind of had it all planned out
that you know he was gonna give us a
preseason game in Buffalo so made it so
it wasn't a regular-season game so made
it a whole lot easier to do everything
that we did we went and made a donation
to the hospital and then to walk on the
field in a opposing stadium and get a
standing ovation is not something that
happens often and so it's pretty crazy
pretty surreal and I mean it was
definitely a cool and special moment
that I just how thankful those fans were
that we got them in the playoffs but for
us we were so thankful for all the money
that they were able to give to our
foundation because we're gonna be able
to help so many children and their
families with it yeah the Roswell Park
Cancer Center angel fund was the
recipient of the the dollars in in
western New York there and you visited
the center the day before the preseason
game
correct correct yeah I didn't think that
I didn't think that I was going to be
able to go it was actually it was
actually the day of the game and so I
had a little time in the house the day
of yeah so again it was good that it was
a preseason game is it things were you
know a little more relaxed but yeah I
was able to go that morning I didn't
think I was gonna be able to but our
schedule worked out where I was able to
make it over there for a little bit and
just you know make the donation just to
say thank you for for all the money that
they gave to us it's just you're right
it is an amazing story it's a and again
the the ovation
I think was just everybody kind of
giving everybody a round of applause
that that obviously it was meant
something football wise but lives were
changed through that that somebody
thought let's let's let's let's make
something special for Andy Dalton and
his family through the foundation I love
that Andy it's it you can't make that up
yeah I think it just shows the power of
sports and how many people it can impact
and especially when when you use it for
good it can it can
make an impact on so many people and so
yeah I think it's like a crazy story
awesome story it's one of those things
that you never think is going to happen
to you you you know is one of those
stories that you see in it's like aw man
that's awesome but not everything is
going to happen to you so we just happen
to be on the receiving end of it and
then just again the story that's
unfolding that the quarter post point of
the Bengal season three and one after
that win Dre Kirkpatrick who's been on
this show many times was saying
afterwards that the teams fighting for
each other standing up for each other
believing in each other in previous
years we haven't had that would you
agree with that assessment
yeah I think definitely this year that
that's the case I think for for us
there's been no quit in this team and we
were finding ways to win however it
needs to be done yeah I felt like this
past week they're the last team that had
the ball was going to win and you know
fortunately we were able to score with
seven seconds left so now I definitely
agree with that statement and that you
know I get guys are definitely playing
for each other
well in terms of past years haven't had
that what do you think he means by that
yeah it's it's hard to say you know I
think that some that he's saying I'm not
necessarily saying that but yeah I think
this year we definitely have that okay
taking on the Miami Dolphins this
weekend Andy Dalton we appreciate you
joining the program thanks very much
we'll chat again soon yeah you got it
thanks you got that sandy Dalton pretty
much has every record at TCU now three
and one for the Cincinnati Bengals right
here in the Rich Eisen show the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience